i don't think i've really ever had
indian food so i'm kind of just
imagining the snacks to be spicy be
pretty spot on
really ever since i was a kid i visited
india like every two years
so i feel like i kind of have a little
bit of the lay of the land over there
my whole family is indian i was raised
indian i was born in india
i lived in india so i definitely say i'm
pretty indian
i'm ready to try this let's do it hey
so this is a like a sweet and spicy
blend of different foods you would eat
out of your
palm i love this stuff i'll go
to the indian store and grab like the
big packs
and eat them within a week my dad really
loves this and we always have to like
sort of hide it
because he always finds it and finishes
the whole bag huge fan of chex mix
the variety is just really impressive
this is very similar to what you have
where it's like a variety pack of
different
snacks combined into one though it is a
variety pack they all
pretty much tasted the same i usually
eat them by kind of
pouring a little bit into my hands here
you go and then
if they're the bigger pieces i'll do
some of this you know
but then eventually i'll just knock them
back you have to have a handful of this
right yeah you gotta combine all the
flavors that's the real way
oh good right this is really good this
is like
definitely less flavorful to me than
that i'm gonna concur that's a gigantic
bag that can't be like for a person
right
i mean i think i could eat it let's not
underestimate ourselves
i would say that's not considered
necessarily a spicy food
like there's definitely some spice to it
it's just not like a tingle in the back
yeah it's not really a lego i can't
really put my
finger on what the flavor is right it's
like a tangy sweet soury just
deliciousness
really good original chex mix it's salt
and
shapes and i like it it's definitely one
large flavor
but i like it's like salty i feel like
the bread is like a little different
tasting right
i see you definitely like something i
would eat more of you know
yeah you can't just have one bite if i
had to pick i'd pick the katamita
these guys right here i would probably
go with the katamita
for the simple fact it has a range of
flavors and i really like the spice
i agree i would still probably choose
the holly roms katamita
this is squirkle and i remember when i
was a kid
there's a pretty famous actress her name
was juhi javla and she was the
spokesperson for this and i loved juhi
java so
obviously i needed to eat these but i
haven't had this flavor which i think
was like the star flavor it's like a
spicy uh
like cheese doodle or something like
that you've had to have had hot cheetos
i have spoiler alert i haven't had hot
cheetos before
spokesperson is chester cheeto here he's
a
like a cheeto leopard he's a cheetah i
mean he's a cheetah of course he's a
cheater
i'm not even gonna sit here and pretend
that i've never eaten a freaking hot
cheeto in my life
i've never had a flaming hot cheeto wait
what i feel like we should be eating our
own snacks yeah
oh yeah nothing like hot cheetos
waiting for this flies one of those
that's gonna build
oh you gotta have it more often yeah
okay so this is
much more approachable i just ate one
that's like a toxic looking like
nuclear red right there it's [ __ ]
great this looks great how you like that
this is good it's actually pretty mild
yeah yeah
oh i mean i love them those have looking
instant like
yeah cheers cheers all right here's your
first hot cheeto hot cheeto yeah i feel
like
welcome to a good life these are
addictive it has like the undercurrent
of like
bleached lined notebook paper this is
disrespect
because these are amazing and if you
don't like them i don't know what to say
to you but at least you like these
like i said i never tried these but in
corn puff version
masala munch is i think i think i like
it better than hot cheetos
if i were to have to choose between the
two i would go with the cheetos
there's like this hint of ramen in here
for me that i'm just like
if i wanted a spicy snack this is ramen
isn't where i'd go
this would be really hard for me because
i like both of them a lot i probably
still would get the masala munch
because after a certain point the
cheetos kind of get a lot in your
stomach so this is partly g
it's probably one of the most
recognizable brands in india this is my
mom's
favorite breakfast cookie she'll dip it
in her morning masala chai
and that's how i grew up eating them i
would also dip them
in overly sweetened masala chai make it
so that they're nice and soggy
and then eat them and they are perfect
for that purpose this child is one of
the most recognizable images i think and
like the fawn everything
it's the gerber baby of america yeah
it's like the gerber bear of india
the gerber baby of india i mean they
taste like crackers we probably should
incorporate tea time
in america with these definitely you're
gonna need something i vaguely remember
these coming in packets similar to like
this
and it was like a cage for like circus
animals and then
oh like that was a fun part of getting
your animal crackers
the reclosable seal is adult we want our
box back
they remind me of like the maria cookies
which is more of a latin american thing
i don't even understand what this flavor
profile is
it's weird it's like sweetened cardboard
it's literally what it reminds me of
you know like i've had that oh they have
the branding everywhere you will know
you know you know oh yeah
i'd tear it through ease it's like a
sweet cracker like a sweet bread yeah
oh with tea time
these are great um i would really like
some coffee
they feel like they'd be really good
like slightly soggy and dipped in a
bitter liquid
i'd rather eat that from this g for
genius
whoever made those it's a little sweet
yeah right
almost like a little bit of a hint of
lemon right
did you ever do the thing where you
would like bite the heads off yeah we
were just like
every kid does that yeah i would say in
my opinion these are sweeter slightly
i would definitely say the parlor g is
much sweeter
oh wow maybe i'm just really used to
this maybe
juicy juice i'm sure other brands made
juice
but everything was called juicy juice
yeah that was juice box that was the one
i don't think you can get more childhood
american than the apple juice juicy
juice i remember there was an ad that
would be like juicy juice 100
juice for 100 kid and my mom would just
be like no
fruity great mango drink
incredible is it only mangoed flavor i
think there's other ones you get but
this one's
particular i feel like the iconic one in
my opinion is mango mango i love mango
so this is
concentrate from chile apparently this
is
fantastic it's mango-y but it also has
like sort of a tea
kind of aftertaste to it like it's like
a generic sort of iced tea kind of
flavor
it's very interesting i love it it's so
good i'm
really into it this is good it's your
run-of-the-mill apple juice and that's
exactly what it tastes like
i don't think i missed out on much i'd
rather have my fruity can we cheers yeah
let's do it oh cheers
oh yeah oh yeah i bet this is made with
like real mango juice
this is definitely sweet for sure but i
still love it it's got that classic
apple juice taste
does it this also has 10 grams more
sugar
than this oh wow kids need one to two
cups of fruit per day
and apparently that comes from juicy
juice
why not have them drink that cup which
by the way doesn't have
any fiber in it which fruit kind of
provides you with
so this doesn't claim to be anything
other than a mango drink you know
doesn't even say mango juice it's mango
trick then go drink
that's how you subvert the law yeah it's
not lying to you it is just as bad
i'm sure there's like 30 grams of sugar
in that thing but it's not pretending to
be a fruit
i like it it's good you can't deny it's
just so good
it's nowhere near as like overpowering
as the juicy juice i'm gonna go with the
foodie i love apple juice apple juice is
one of my favorite
juices but fruity for sure well my
favorite part of juice box is ready
yeah oh i gotta come catch up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you